I of course like many packages in
libraries in Python but probably my
favorite package of all time is pandas I
love it because it's just plain super
easy to use and makes sense for a lot of
my workflows in data science that said I
also like machine learning and data sets
can often get quite large for example
we'll play with the data set today from
kaggle of UK property prices with over
28 million rows of data using vanilla
pandas for this despite how awesome it
really is as a library and how efficient
it is out of the box arguably uh it
would and will be very slow in the past
I've simply employed the skill of
patience for this problem but today I'd
like to show you the pandas accelerator
from nvidia's Rapids Arsenal using KF
which is a GPU accelerated data frame
Library historically this library has
been a bit of a challenge to deploy
because if you wanted to use CDF you
needed to completely adopt qdf and make
sure every operation that you performed
in your program was function within CF
and given the scope of operations even
in a simple project this made CF almost
unusable in practice no matter how fast
it ran for certain specific commands and
then even if you did have full and
perfect coverage you'd still have to
refactor all of your code which no Dev
really wants to do and then you'd
probably have to maintain separate
branches and all that nobody wants that
instead what Nvidia has done is
introduced a way to deploy C with a mere
module flag when running the script or
through an extension load in a notebook
and that's it there's no other change
necessary with a slight asterisk of
maybe sometimes being explicit with data
types uh otherwise you might run into
some problems and this came up in my
testing and I'll share with you all what
I ran across U but at least in my
testing so far this is basically fair to
say a dropin functionality replacement
that you should could absolutely be
using right now today and from now on
with your Panda data frames this also
includes even if you just so happen to
be using a library that also uses pandas
itself because it will also accelerate
that too in order to install it's just a
pip install cf- q11 or q12 for the Cuda
version that you're running so let's see
just how much performance we can get
with a mere flag I'm going to run the CF
pandas accelerator on the left and then
regular pandas on the right we could use
the kind of time it magic and all of
that but this does weird things with
variables and is really only useful for
getting a really solid concrete sort of
average time um so my test here isn't
going to be the most perfect of timing
tests but it's a real comparison
nonetheless and the kind of the
difference between CDF and regular
pandas is on the orders of like
magnitudes right so so um we're not
going to have um an issue with a ten of
a second here and there there so anyways
uh just know that this is basically it's
just one pass through it's not the most
perfect comparison but it's good enough
because the difference in performance
here is massive so the first sell in
this notebook is just loading the
accelerator for CF and then I just have
like a comment for the other one which
is our regular pandas between the two
notebook files this is actually the only
difference these are otherwise identical
notebooks uh so next what we're going to
do is we're going to load the data into
a data frame note that I'm explicitly
setting the data type for price as int64
and this is what I was talking about
earlier the reason for this is in the
data set itself in that CSV file it has
these prices in in quotes like a string
pandas with regular old python actually
still magically handles for this and
allows us to perform math operations on
strings as if they were ins um or even
floats and this is just I don't know
some magic going on in the back end of
of pandas to kind of handle for this
when people do this um but but if you
are having a problem with like in
Infinity numbers and stuff like that
you'll want to go ahead and look at your
data set and see if it's doing this cuz
in my opinion this isn't really I'm not
sure this is something I would expect
anybody to handle for even pandas but
just keep in mind that this could be a
thing in your data set that panas is
just somehow magically handling for but
anyways you're going to want to either
make sure your data set doesn't do this
or you can explicitly set data types to
handle for it just in case it does as
you can see even just loading the data
frame into memory sees a mass M boost of
a mirror only like 2.9 seconds to load
with qdf compared to almost a minute
with regular pandas the first time I ran
through with CF I actually found that
both took quite a bit of time to load
after some debugging I realized that it
was actually me loading from my Nas
rather than from like a local storage on
that machine so network storage versus
local storage so just in case you're as
dense as I am uh make sure your data is
actually local so in this case it's on
an nvme so it's much much faster to load
instead of of loading over Network once
it's in memory though it's kind of
irrelevant where the data set started
from so it's all kind of a wash from
there okay so from this point we can do
a quick operation just to make sure
things are working as intended and we'll
get the length of the data frame which
looks good and is as expected so then
what we can do is grab all of the unique
towns and cities interestingly enough
there is a slight Delta here in favor of
regular CPU pandas the reason here is
likely this is a CPU only oper ation so
then you're paying for some data
transfer and overhead going CPU back to
GPU and I think that's the difference
that said you're about to see why this
difference is insignificant and
irrelevant but you might also wonder
what if you did a larger amount of these
unique operations I don't think I've
ever done a unique call in a loop but
what if you did since I already had to
redo this video once I went ahead and
just did a quick test for this
particular operation I looped through
just over all of the columns and grabbed
uniques from each of them and it's still
just a CPU only operation but you can
clearly see uh it's not like CPU to GPU
transfer is actually causing a 2X
slowdown if you were to need to scale
out a unique operation for any reason um
and actually it even looks like the kdf
version was slightly faster for this run
that's probably just by chance if like I
I was saying before if we use the time
it module for like little tiny
differences like this we might find that
either they basically identical or maybe
sometimes the the CPU is faster or
whatever but anyway I just wanted to
further poke into this and make sure
that the overhead was actually as
irrelevant as I was pretty sure it was
and in this case it definitely is so now
what we're going to do is get the
average home price for each unique town
or city this operation takes qdf 10 and
1 12 seconds for regular pandas it takes
19 minutes uh 10 seconds versus 19
minutes is absolutely insane and again
this is a zero effort switch if you
already have an Nvidia GPU you've
already got Cuda all that it's it you
just install KF you call the flag and
boom you're done the same code also can
run on the GPU if it's available or it
could be CPU only so you don't even need
two separate code bases continuing on
what we're going to do is we'll slice
out just the year 2022 from this data
frame and get just pricing information
for that year surprisingly to me this
operation was also orders of magnitude
faster with KF than without this is
surprising because these dates were not
even read in as daytime objects or
anything fancy at all they're actually
simply strings and the actual operation
that per we're performing here to do
that slice is actually just a string dot
starts withth so this means there's
actually some fancy kouf GPU method for
string operations which is particularly
impressive and something that I did not
at least personally expect to see here
and that brings us to the profiler this
lets us see exactly what's happening
either closer to the qdf backend showing
us the operations running on cdf's side
of things and what device it's running
on GPU or CPU and then how long that's
taking alternatively we can also use the
line profiler to show us sort of line by
line what's running on the CPU or GPU
and how long that's taking so here we
can see both the line profile and just
regular profile on that data frame slice
line profile shows us that actually that
line of code is indeed done entirely on
the GPU we can then use the profiler to
see what KF is actually doing and we can
see that there's a get item method and
then that we do indeed have string
Methods which includes some fancy starts
withth functionality allowing this to
run entirely on the GPU despite the fact
that it's just string operations which
is particularly awesome next maybe we
want to calculate the upper and lower
20% of home prices to discover areas
with the most variance so here's a
slightly longer bit of code we can again
see that CDF is considerably faster here
by about five times and we can also do a
line profile here to see what's going on
finally from here after pulling all this
kind of data we might do something like
some pure python code to grab ratios for
high and low as well as maybe get an
actual range and then kind of display
maybe where are the biggest variants
and stuff like that so then finally just
a couple of quick common commands like
finding the max for a column and a sort
to just show off some more operations
but I really encourage you to install CF
and just use it on your own projects and
stuff like that just to see how much
faster it is and see what else might
even just surprise you cuz like I said I
I had seen some of the demos but then
there were things that I just did not
expect to be the case and that were
definitely the case and and that was
pretty cool to see so anyway uh you can
try the pandas uh accelerator yourself
yourself via CDF by installing with Pip
install cf- q11 or Q2 also of note you
can run scripts too so obviously not
just notebooks and the way that you can
do this is with just the kf. pandas
module flag when you go to run that
actual script and you'll get all the
same performance speed UPS so that's all
I have to show for now this pandas
accelerator from KF is freaking awesome
I love how darn simple the
implementation of it really is and I
look forward to seeing how this like
rapid stuff just evolves over time this
is been many years in the making and
this is oh such a cool update to see so
if you have an Nvidia GPU and you find
yourself using pandas definitely try it
out let me know what you think uh if you
find anything in particularly
interesting or if you're having a hard
time with something leave a comment
below um I really was just pretty
surprised at just how fast everything
actually is how well everything just
simply works if there isn't something it
just falls back to the CPU but like I
said there was more coverage for GPU
operations than I even expected like the
string Methods and that was just super
super cool to see I'll leave uh pip
install commands and an example of
running the script via the terminal in
the description there's also an official
collab notebook example from the Rapids
team that I will put in there as well
and then finally there was an AI data
science Summit from Nvidia very recently
that also showcased this uh Panda's
accelerator which you can also watch
I'll put a link to that in the
description as well anyway I hope you
all have enjoyed and learned a cool new
tool I'm definitely going to be using
this personally from now on and I will
see you all in a another
video